disparos cuchillos y explosiones en el
centro carcelario más grande de ecuador
el amotinamiento en la penitenciaría de
guayaquil dejó 24 reclusos fallecidos y
al menos 48 heridos
los presos dispararon desde las ventanas
de la prisión en medio de humo gritos y
detonaciones de explosivos las
autoridades ecuatorianas explicaron que
la disputa fue causada por las bandas
delincuenciales recluidas llamadas dos
globos y los choneros de la muerte que
se dan aquí en el pabellón número cinco
es una ala de este pabellón que son de
una banda delictiva y querían que esta
banda se cambie y sean de la otra que
pertenecen a los pabellones de ocho y
nueve entonces los lleva bajo no han
querido cambiarse de banda es por eso
que les empiezan a eliminar después de
cinco horas de un operativo de control
policial y militar volvió la calma lo
importante es que hoy podemos dormir
tranquilos porque la policía nacional
junto a las fuerzas de orden táctico de
la policía ha logrado restablecer el
control
según el sistema nacional de información
del país tan solo en lo corrido del 2021
se han registrado 140 muertes en centros
carcelarios de ecuador el más sangriento
ocurrió en febrero cuando 79 presos
murieron en varios motines que
sucedieron simultáneamente en tres
cárceles de distintas ciudades del país
pese a que el presidente ecuatoriano
guillermo lasso declaró el estado de
emergencia en el sistema penitenciario
los episodios de violencia dentro de las
cárceles son constantes